everyone talks about passion legacy
purpose yeah yeah the one word to pay
attention to is I think you should chase
what energizes you everyone talks about
passion legacy purpose yeah yeah the one
word to pay attention to his energy I
love that that's it let's simplify this
okay so whatever energizes you naturally
expands you feels like possibility is
exciting to do and maybe scary that
doesn't matter
it has to do with how it makes you feel
right when you were in your 20s money
made you feel good it expanded you it
energized you chasing the money that was
the game that was your passion that was
your per there's nothing wrong with that
nothing wrong with that and I
particularly want to say that to the
women that are well yeah because it is
socialized into women not to chase
success like that not to go after the
money and so if what energizes you is
amassing wealth go for it but what
happened and and the reason why I say
that is because people talk about the
word passion yeah or purpose right and
the truth is it's not a person place or
a thing it's not it is the feeling
of being expanded and energized right if
you're pursuing your passion it means
that you wake up every day and are
energized so instead of trying to think
what's my purpose what's my passion was
my purpose what's my passion
yeah instead of thinking like that I
want you instead to ask yourself what's
what could I do today that would
energize me what energizes me if it's
making money
figure out how to make money there if it
is making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's thrilling yeah
thrilling there is nothing more
exhilarating than making your first
million yeah nothing more exhilarating
but what happens is once you learn how
to do something once you can do it over
and over again and so it starts to
become routine yeah which means it's no
longer energizing right which is why
every entrepreneur out there goes
through the mode of chasing the money
and then you hit the money that you need
to make then you're like I'm not
fulfilled yeah do that finally you know
I do that yeah and it's because you were
energized by the money and now you're
not yeah now you've got to be energized
by the next thing yeah I'm gonna go in a
different direction on this one
there's definitely something more
exciting than chasing your first million
and you don't have to keep chasing the
next thing and wondering what the next
thing is and keep chasing not having
clarity finding your purpose guys is not
that difficult it's not that difficult
it's one of the most common questions
that I get here's how you do it you
think about the time in your life where
you felt the most worthless think about
the time the lowest low that you've ever
experienced in your life what was that
moment your purpose now where you will
get the most fulfilled of all time will
be helping people who are currently
going through the thing that you went
through that's it think about the most
painful moments of your life the thing
that you would never want to experience
ever again think about the thing you
would never wish upon your worst enemy
definitely not your friends your family
your kids think about that moment your
greatest purpose your greatest enjoyment
your greatest fulfillment in life will
come from helping people who are
currently facing that thing that you
faced that is your purpose for life it
will never get old helping those people
will never
get tiring I love helping entrepreneurs
why why do I spend so much time helping
entrepreneurs why am i doing my tour why
am i posting three times a day on
YouTube
why are posting six times a day in
Instagram why do all this work helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as it not turn to myself because
when I was 19 and started my business
and I was struggling and I was failing
and I was making $300 a month and I was
too embarrassed to tell my friends that
I couldn't barely survive that was
making no money
when I turned down these high-paying
jobs I was embarrassed I was ashamed I
told my business partner once that I
quit I felt so bad about myself as a
human so once I made it I built my
business I sold it I had success the
greatest joy in life for me comes from
still helping those pure startup
entrepreneurs I love helping people
who've already made it get to the next
level I love helping somebody who has a
million revenue and help them get to two
and five and ten it's great but I
resonates so much more where the
person's just getting started who's
struggling who's afraid who's putting in
tons of work and not seeing results and
that will be my purpose for life you can
find your purpose the exact same way and
then have clarity for the rest of your
life and you don't have to chase one
thing and then another thing and then
another thing and now I'm in it for
money and I'm in for this you'll have to
do that here's where I really agree with
Mal on chasing energy I love the idea of
chasing energy within your purpose so
you found out your why right that's your
why the next step is you figure out your
how the how is how are you going to
fulfill it so it's great that I love
helping entrepreneurs amazing how am I
going to do that there's a lot of
different ways for me to do it and that
will change and that's where I can chase
energy so as an example I started with
my website I start with my website I
love the idea of having a place for
people to come to and consume content
and have I had a hundred thousand plus
pieces of content on my website and then
I started experimenting with YouTube
just as something to test and play
around with and I love that even more
and so eventually I shut down my website
I closed my 8 people who are on that
team brought them all over to YouTube
then scaled my team to have 24 people
who's helping me with my YouTube
business because that was where my
energy was going the website could still
work there's lots of ways to win but my
energy was over here I love YouTube I
love making videos much more than
writing content recently in the past six
months I felt a lot of energy going to
my Instagram why did I pick up Instagram
why have I gone so hardcore on Instagram
because I went on and I did an Instagram
live session and I realized that when
you did Instagram live you could bring
people in picture-in-picture that I
could be coaching and helping somebody
from my place in Toronto to somebody
here in Columbus where I'm at now or
Chicago or Zambia or anywhere in the
world and I could see them because when
you get text questions on a YouTube live
you can't go deep you can't get the
context you can't ask back and forth
because it's very rarely the question
somebody comes in at with the actual
question that's buried deep below the
thing they actually need to work on but
when you have them picture-in-picture
and I'm a visual learners for a love be
able to see people's reactions when I
can see them there I can help them a lot
more and that Instagram live alone is
the thing that got me to play a much
bigger game on Instagram in the past six
months have grown my account from 8,000
followers of soda a hundred thousand now
my energy is going there and so where
the energy goes right results will
follow but it's still within my purpose
of helping entrepreneurs and so you
don't have to stumble around through
life chasing one thing and then the next
and the next
when you have your clarity of purpose it
makes everything so much easier but then
chase the energy within that purpose
because the how will change a million
times because YouTube for me won't be
around in ten years maybe it's still
here but it won't be the same thing
adventure is gonna be Evan coming to you
in holographic format you know or it's
gonna be VR Evan coming at you but it's
my purpose for life to help
entrepreneurs
and you could figure out yours just as
easily go to that deepest moment go to
those painful moment that's gonna be
your purpose for ever helping other
people never have to experience that
thing that you felt worthless for that's
it
now I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what was your deepest darkest
most painful moment and how has that
transitioned to your purpose I'd love to
hear from you please leave it in the
comments below
here's how you develop a passion it
starts as a minor area of interest you
gain areas of interest by encountering a
lot of stuff so if you haven't countered
a lot of things in your life go out
there and encounter stuff go sailing go
take a dance class go study neuroscience
like whatever it is just encounter a
whole bunch of very broad diverse things
from that you're gonna get sparks of
interest like oh I actually found that
interesting I want to learn more dive
deep through engagement not through
pondering through engagement you're
going to realize whether something is
gonna turn into an area of fascination
so as you go deeper into it you're gonna
either become fascinated or you're not
if you're not fascinated move on if you
are fascinated then that's an area where
you're gonna ask yourself one very
simple question do I want to become the
best in the world at that thing if you
do if you want to become truly
extraordinary in that thing then go down
the path of gaining mastery now the
reason I think that it's wise to ask
that question going in is when you frame
it up I'm gonna become the best in the
world at this immediately people
understand the amount of time energy and
weight that it would take to become
truly great at that thing and I don't
think that passion can happen unless
you're becoming truly great at that
thing that's part of passion I don't
think people are deeply passionate about
something that they really suck at and
I'll give you an example I love video
games I absolutely love playing
first-person shooters I learn a lot from
them I get a lot out of them
I really just intrinsically enjoy the
time it has both that sense of eating a
cake because it's just fun in the moment
and it I pull from it life lessons
business lessons I practice getting out
of the sympathetic nervous system into
the parasympathetic nervous system it's
literally gamified so I'm getting better
I have points I can
you know have my improvement turned into
metrics it's all of it I really really
enjoy but I won't say that I'm deeply
passionate about it I'm just not that
good at it so it's one of those things
if I really wanted to develop a deep
passion for video video games and put it
at the center of my life that then I
would set down that path of really
practicing now
this is like this is the most important
thing that passion will do for you which
is it's gonna pull you through boredom
it's gonna pull you through the hard
times and that's why it's really got to
be something that you just are prepared
to become great at because when you're
prepared to become great there's just
these insane moments of boredom
repetition and all of that and if you
have this burgeoning passion coming out
of that that's what's gonna give you the
energy to get through it so it's this
symbiotic relationship between a
developing passion and how hard it is to
actually really get great at something
so the things you get great at need to
be something that is this developing
passion so there you have it that's how
you do it and that's why you do it and
if you want more Mel Robbins check out
the five hacks and strategies to
transform your life video the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there my name is very simple
completed the day and leave no tasks
that I have to finish in the morning